Crow's transformation you created a
documentary so you took a step forward
tell us about that we did it for three
years before even my first hormone shot
and it goes through my whole journey of
going through the hormones going through
the surgeries it has the social changes
the physical changes the emotional
changes it kind of highlights everything
that happens throughout a transition
it's really important to kind of use
that to educate people so people can
understand the process better because
there's not really many films that
actually have how the process works do
you have family and friends support
going through all of this absolutely how
important was that it was so important I
probably couldn't do it without my mom
because she's such a big part of my life
remember how scary it is for them to
come forward and to come to you and just
say this is what's happening with me I
need you Kroy was at this year's
Canadian arts and Fashion Awards where
our own Sangeeta fatale presented him
with the fresh face of the Year honor
what was that moment like for you oh my
god it was incredible
just to be part of that and to be
representing Canada is just amazing
because it's representing Canada across
the world it's incredible to be able to
have fashion as a platform to bring
awareness to the trans community and
people who are going through struggles
whether it's physically emotionally
mentally and kind of give that support
to the community and have fashion really
embrace that the biggest change that I
notice from the last time we work
together is how happy you look you are
radiating happiness what do you feel
like knowing that people are looking up
to you and asking you questions about
what you're going through and helping
them and making their transition a
peaceful one it's really incredible
because in the end it can save lives
just having people be informed and know
that this is something that's totally
normal and when you're transitioning
you're still the same person at heart
it's just a physical change and you're
still the same one that everyone loves
so our same heart
[Music]